hey everybody you know what time it is
it's time for another rollback what is
rollback rollback is the best podcast
episodes from the past the old Audio
Only days brought now directly to you
right here on YouTube for the very first
time and today we're featuring The Man
Behind the wildly successful 2010
documentary film fat sick and nearly
dead his name is Joe Cross 100 pounds
overweight loaded up on prescription
meds and suffering from a debilitating
autoimmune disease Joe Cross was a man
on the brink he was a guy at the end of
his robe with doctors and conventional
medicines just unable to really help him
long term
so what happens well Joe ends up turning
to the only option left the body's
ability to heal itself and he does what
anyone would do he hits the road with a
juicer and a film crew in tow vowing
only to drink fresh fruit and vegetable
juice for 60 days across 3 000 miles Joe
has only one goal in mind get off all of
his pills his meds and achieve a
balanced lifestyle and in this episode
number 47 from all the way back in
September of 2013 Joe and I get into how
he changed his life how he helped to
create a populist movement around
juicing and healthy lifestyle we talk
about his passion for health and
self-healing and I really hope that you
are inspired by his infectious energy by
his message which is really to take your
own Wellness into your own hands and to
the next level so here we go this is me
and Joe Cross
you know there's a lot of overlap in our
stories I think we're about the same age
I'm about to turn 47. yeah
right me too so by a horse
and we both had these kind of enough is
enough Epiphany moments at age 40 like
me right before I turned 40 you at 40. I
mean we're you know our stories kind of
diverge you're you're certainly your
health was a little bit more of a dire
circumstance than mine was at the time
but we both kind of kick-started this
New Path on juicing I I my juice cleanse
was only seven days and for me that was
enough to really reboot to use your
phrase you know everything that I was
doing and it was it was an incredibly
powerful
you know number of days where I felt
like I could wipe the Slate clean and
start fresh and so as much of a physical
change as it it entailed it was also
very much like a mental cleansing like I
can you know I've done I've endured this
seven days I feel different now now I
can go on a new trajectory and one of
the things that I found so striking in
your film was as you were traveling
across the country and you're meeting
all these people
you would meet these people who are
obviously you know in in poor physical
health and you say hey I'm doing in in a
very friendly non-judgmental way saying
hey I'm doing this juicing what you know
what would you what would you think if I
told you about nothing but juice for the
last 40 days or whatever and you know
they'd look at you curiously and then
just sort of dismiss it you know as
impossible or not something they're
interested in doing and you'd be like
okay nice to meet you you never judge
them and
and and what I took from that is this
gap between
what needs to be done and where we're at
in the sense that you know we have this
obesity crisis and you lay out the
statistics in the movie where you know
this the 60 35 5 percentages 60 of the
calories that um that we eat are coming
from processed foods
uh 40 from animal products 30 from
animal products five percent from grains
and five percent from fruits and
vegetables right and uh and just to
convince people to take that five
percent and expand it is is such a
challenge and yet you know people are
suffering from diabetes and heart attack
I mean even with Phil's brother who
suffered a heart attack he still you
could tell was struggling with this idea
of embarking on this journey that
literally had transformed his brother's
life so so what we're dealing with here
is really a psychology issue as much as
anything else with that question and and
for me I know just in my personal
struggles
you know people say oh people don't
change and and I disagree with that
people do change but people change when
they're ready to change and people
change usually people change when
they're in pain or the pain becomes
intolerable enough that it motivates
them sufficiently to make a change and
and for me that's been the case and and
so I guess the challenge is how do you
catalyze that change without people
having to hit the kind of bottom that
you had to hit or that I had to hit or
that Phil had to hit yeah and it's a
it's a good step
it's a very good question and I think
that like what you're doing and what I'm
doing and what there's so many others
that are in our sort of
shoes are trying to do is to find out
ways because I don't think there's one
answer that fits all I think
you know just take America for example I
think there's 316 million
um people in this country or 316 million
that means there's 316 million different
diets you know and and different ways to
go about being the best they can be
and so what I think is really important
is not to be too preachy not to be too
like
um I've got all the the answers and if
you sit and listen to me you know I'll
tell you what to do and and you know I'm
very conscious of just the way I even
speak like
saying you know I I'd like to help
people get healthy you know just using
the words I'm getting them I'm actually
not getting them I like to use the word
I'm inspiring people or I'm helping or
you know what I mean it's they're subtle
words but they make a big difference in
people the way they listen and you know
quite often when I talk to to to uh
crowds when I do my uh demos or or talks
I ask the question you know hands up
those out there that really love being
told what to do you know might be a
thousand people in the audience and no
one puts their hand up and if they do
then you know they're joking but you
know no one really loves being told what
to do and then you ask the question how
many people love telling people what to
do and of course all the hands go up
right so there epitomizes the Big
Challenge in the world today is that
people love giving orders I mean people
like taking them and so I don't think
that people in your shoes or mine that
have a fortunate enough to have a
platform where people are listening to
what we have to say I mean they're
interested enough in what we've done
that they want to listen to what we're
saying so I think it's it's really
important to be humble I know you are
about that I've only just met you but I
can tell already that you're humble
about that I'm I'm very conscious of of
that
and I think that the more humble you can
be the more understanding the more
forgiving the more that you don't have
the answers the more that you are honest
and transparent and share I think that
resonates with people
because you know I've got a saying which
I really have um I've been using it for
a long time I don't even know where I
learned it from I I know someone told me
but I've forgotten so I'd like to credit
that person but it's like that the
crowds are dumb but people are really
smart
and so when you're talking about things
like this to people out there that are
listening every single one of them is
really really smart nobody needs URI to
come along and say guess what fruits and
vegetables they've got all this powerful
stuff they're really good for you I mean
they know that right people know this
stuff it's not about the knowing it's
about the doing now there are some
things that they can learn and there's
interesting stuff that can I like to say
you know at least you know they can
remember what they've forgotten so it's
it's to me it's about storytelling it's
about uh leading by example it's about
making it fun and interesting and you
know and it's not trying to give too
much uh of this this information over
little bits little nuggets that you can
do little things that can make a big
difference and don't try and do
everything all in one day because it's a
it's it's it's like you've gotta you
gotta you gotta I mean
people talking about rebooting a lot I
mean and and what I've found and what
we're going to talk about hopefully in
movie number two or three and this is
like an example we're just trying to
work out where it fits in but
you know I use the analogy of of going
to a swimming pool and people getting
wet you know how like you go to a pool
and people who are getting out of the
pool they're all wet everyone's wet
you don't actually know how they got wet
did they dive in or did they walk in the
end of the day they got wet I like to
think about analogy of healthy to being
wet so people can get healthy did they
dive in or did they walk in to their
challenge or their their journey of
getting healthy so like a reboot is
really a diving it's like you know right
I'm taking my five percent of plants to
a hundred percent for like you did seven
days I did I did 60 plus 90 I did like
the whole nine yards
um some people that's not going to work
for them right some people just can't go
cold turkey or bang to that some people
that's what they want so they're the
dive in people others like to walk in
and go slowly so I think it's important
to be aware that you've got all these
different ways that people can achieve
this and and so you know it's a it's a
good question you ask but I feel that if
we if we can come at it from these
angles that we can we can have the most
impact right I mean I think that one of
the things that you do and that I always
try to bear in mind in the way that I
speak to people and kind of deliver the
messages I'm not I'm not telling people
what to do I'm not even trying to give
advice I'm just sharing my experience
yes this is what I did this is what
happened to me and you can draw your own
inferences and I have my opinions around
that but it's not my place to impose
them upon you and I think you did you
were you you handle that very definitely
in the movie by just saying hey this is
what I'm doing like come on this journey
with me or not it's cool like I'm just
cruising across the country you know
what I mean like exactly want to juice
out of my car you know well because you
have that attitude is why your your
podcast is so successful that's because
I mean if you and I get on on the
airwaves start screaming out I mean well
and I don't have I have people on that
have a completely different dietary you
know approach than I do I mean I it's
just like let's be adults and have a
conversation we can we can get along
like it's just a food Choice exactly
um we've all got to put energy in our
body regions I look at it this way you
know we've all got a we are consumers of
energy that's what we are humans we're
massive consumers of energy and we need
energy to live if we don't get energy
into our body it's very simple we will
die we are we are driven to be alive
that's what we want to do our three
trillion cells their whole mission is to
stay alive and so they need energy at
that cellular level to convert to stay
alive and we've only when you really
think about it you know we've got air
we've got water we've got food they're
our primary three own main energy
sources and you know you can talk about
love and intimacy and you can and I
believe in that but I'm talking about
physical things that go into your body
and when you then look at the air and
the water and food and you know you and
I can't do much about our water and air
I mean you know that's a big picture
problem right that that that's that's
macro stuff
but the food is the real micro one that
we can actually have some kind of a
saying we can actually choose what sort
of food energy we decide to to feed our
body and I like to think about it very
simply because I think people respond I
know I do to Simple Things I mean so
much confusion out there and I think
breaking it down to very simple
um
philosophy or logic is helpful and
you've got
three types of food you can eat you can
eat plants you can eat animal you can
eat processed food and that's it they're
the three and
each one of those three groups of course
that you've got protein carbohydrate
you've got sugars you've got fat you've
got all that but you know what let's
let's leave that aside for the moment
let's just look at the three categories
you know plants animal processed
and I like to think that you know
they're the three
um to choose from and I like to put the
processed and the animal in what I call
the fun part of town okay and I like to
put the plants in the essential part of
town now I'm sure for someone like you
the plants are the fun part of town but
let's just let's just let's just talk
about the massive we're gonna fight now
no no no the masses of people that are
out there I I understand what you're
saying completely so so we all know what
happens when you spend too much time in
the fun part of town you know what it
ain't fun anymore
fun fun is defined by only doing it
every now and then otherwise it's not
fun you do something all the time it's
not fun so we have
gone down this path where as we talked
about those numbers earlier where you
know it's actually 93 I've learned have
been since the first movie it's 93 of
our energy on average for the average
American Australian person in Great
Britain you know Western World 93 of our
energy is coming from what I'm calling
the fun part of town seven percent is
coming from the essential part of town
and so when you when you look at that
you cannot ignore the biological laws of
cause and effect as Dr Joel Furman says
in my film you cannot you can't ignore
that and you're going to have this this
epidemic of disease and and unhappiness
and so I think laying that out and
understanding that just on a base level
for anybody to understand those those
three you know categories
and then it's up to you and and the
people out there I believe to decide
what what number do you want your plant
intake to be do you want it to be from
seven if you're average do you want to
go to ten do you want to go to 15 do you
want to go to 40 do you want to go to
100 it's up to you right well I think
there's a a couple things I mean when
you talk about spending too much time in
the fun part of town that begs the
question of sort of moderation versus
extreme behavior and some would say that
for you to go on this juice cleanse this
juice fast for 60 days plus the 90 that
came after it or for me to be 100
plant-based and go to these crazy
endurance races those are extreme
behaviors and I think you know well
they'd be wrong yeah we just met but I
think we're on the uh where we share a
similar wavelength where I'm attracted
to that kind of challenge or and and I I
almost need that like I needed to do the
juice fast to wipe the table clean and
start fresh and I need to challenge
myself I need to jump in with both feet
I need to do something extreme in order
to alter my status quo and my behavior
your patterns and and when I jump in and
do something like that that's outside of
my comfort zone or scares me that that
energizes me and also there's a momentum
that develops behind that and I think a
big part of this is momentum and I think
a big part of your message and this
whole reboot is about generating
momentum because even if you do one day
of juice fasting and then you got
through it then maybe you'll do a second
one or you'll be more energized or
enthusiastic or motivated to continue
but there are people who say well I'm
not ready to dive in you know I just
want to dip my toe in and start to get
wet that way
I don't necessarily relate to those
people but I agree with you that they
exist and and that you know there needs
to be a path for them as well
um I think it's harder to create
momentum behind what they're trying to
do if they're just they're sort of one
foot in and one foot out
um
and I find that those are the people who
most often come to me and say well
what's wrong with moderation what's
wrong with moderation and and I'm
interested in kind of how you respond to
that I'm sure you get that question all
the time I mean for me I say well what
are we talking about here because I
think we we've skewed what moderation
really is like tell me what you're
eating and we'll see if it's truly
moderate or not that's right now and I'm
willing to bet you know looking at you
unhealthy person that what you're doing
probably isn't moderation and I I I I
understand exactly and relate to it
so you know I think first of all I think
I know that you feel this way because
you've sort of hinted it already in our
chat that just because you do something
extreme doesn't make you better or worse
it just makes absolutely different and
that's a key right just to understand
our differences amongst ourselves is
important because I think what can sort
of tend to happen is people feel that
because someone does something to an
extreme that they're trying to be better
than other people or they're trying to
prove a point or it's about ego as
opposed to being about spirit
so
let's assume that all everything we're
talking about is coming from the the
angle of spirit
and if that's the case then you know
just today take America today there is
going to be someone that's the oldest
person in America today and there's
going to be someone who's just born and
then there's going to be a whole bunch
of Ages and we're going to have this
beautiful gasconi and bell curve that I
used to spend so much time on when I was
back in the financial markets in my
previous life and the the the normalized
distribution of of any sample set of
data
um shows that there are things on the
extreme the oldest person the youngest
person you can do it with weight you can
do it with height you can do it with
anything and you can also do it with
your attitude to life and so you're
gonna get this medium or or standard
deviation one which is the most of what
what's average or what's balanced or
what's what's the middle now when it
comes to what we're eating and that
lifestyle I couldn't agree with you more
that it is so skewed so far from really
if you if you were to get a lot of great
minds of um from all walks of life be it
from from the medical world but from the
scientific World be it from spiritual
world and you had a sort of a consensus
of what is the best thing for people to
eat there's no question that what we're
eating on average is so far skewed to an
extreme that that having 93 of our
energy coming from from plant and uh and
process it's really second third and
fourth hand energy I mean we're not
getting the energy directly from where
it's produced so low on the food chain
yeah yeah it very much so so I think
that that when I get asked these
questions about Joe that's pretty
extreme doing 60 days of juice and then
90 days of just eating fruit vegetables
nuts beans and seeds and some whole
grains I go yeah it was but the reason
why I I chose to do that was because I
had this awareness and and aha moment
that I was actually extreme the other
way so we'll see where my life was was
actually I was maintaining this I was
like redlining this extremity the
opposite direction my lifestyle choices
you know my
my diet and my smoking my alcohol intake
my my drink intake be it you know sodas
and milkshakes and so on uh my lack of
exercise my stress levels my lack of
sleep
um my anger all of those things I mean
you know you look at all the lifestyle
choices I mean I'm Red Lion in the light
I'm I'm getting a big fat F in all of
them if I have to score myself so no
wonder I'm 300 and you know 10 320
pounds no wonder I'm on medication night
and day for eight years no wonder I'm
I'm uh you know one foot in the grave no
wonder a minimal walking time bomb so
and I'm only 40. I was actually 32 to 40
for that period
um so
I I look at that as an extreme and then
I I needed to go the other way
to that extreme to find the balance
right and I'm not saying I found it now
I mean I'm still trying but you know you
know the other way I look at it rich is
I sort of go you know go down to um I
think we can learn a lot from kids I
think kids can really teach us a lot so
I go down to any playground
anywhere in the world and we call them a
seesaw in Australia you know what I'm
talking about so I said the fulcrum of
the balance of this you saw tipping from
one answer yeah so hopefully everyone
understands the Seesaw around America
because sometimes we have different
words here but the Seesaw I challenge
you to look at any two kids that get on
a seesaw you know what kids love to do
they love to get to that balancing point
where both kids feet are off the ground
but I've never seen kids that can go
there straight away they've got to go
high low high low do do slowly slowly
slowly to get to balance I think that's
kind of like with us as well we've got
to go and explore these extremes to see
and experience and to feel and to know
and then we have our own boundaries set
our own guidelines set so that we can
then go you know what that kind of
extreme of just drinking juice well that
was really cool I don't think that
there's something I should do the rest
of my life now logically that doesn't
make sense and that's probably not
healthy because we know it isn't if you
just juice only so likewise living on
you know
when I used to go to McDonald's I would
order a a Big Mac a quarter pounder
cheese a cheeseburger a large fries a
chocolate shake I love it chocolate
sundae and get this a Diet Coke and down
your apple pie did you say that no the
chocolate Sun okay I don't know apple
pie didn't have enough sugar in it for
me so it was like no double
cheeseburgers no we didn't have them
back in there we did no okay well we
were pretty like you know vanilla menu
down in Australia so anyway so you know
that's a 16 meal right do you know let
me let me just uh interrupt you for one
second do you in uh in Australia do you
know Andrew G Austin Pennsburg yeah yeah
okay so he's a friend of mine I had him
on the podcast and he calls it the
window diet he said if they roll down
the window and they hand it to you you
eat it I like that I like that well of
course I'd never get out of the car
while I get out of the car when they can
you know you can drive up and you know
yeah why expand that energy right I mean
come on so so I think that when you go
when you explore both extremes and and
so I think I think the answer is is that
for for what we're trying to get the
long answer your question
which is that
you know extremes
um the reason why I think a reboot works
for so many people
is it's doing two things it's it's
taking out a lot of the the animal and
the process so it's giving our our
system a break
from having to deal with that type of
energy number one and then the flip side
is because we're we're supercharging
with the uh you know I call it
freebasing mother nature because we're
actually putting this uh High Rich
energy in your body's never it's never
had that experience of being flooded
with so much phytonutrients and and you
know and liquid sunshine it's never it's
never had that before so you get this
this this two this this flip side going
on which is working to really take you
to another level and I think what it
does it resets the taste buds it takes
you to this high like from the from the
valley to the top of the mountain and if
anyone who's been in a valley knows you
don't get much of a view but when you're
on top of a mountain Boy The View can be
just spectacular and that's addictive
that is that's that's a real
um uh natural high and so that in itself
I think all of that what I just talked
about
creates this this this like falling back
in love with fruits and vegetables and
you have this this this this romantic uh
feeling that wow this stuff's really
good you know and it's almost like we've
been cheating on it it's like we've been
cheating on a partner for like the last
80 years I mean for thousands of years
we were pretty happy with our plants you
know we we sort of with them and we
turned our back on them and so now we're
sort of paying the penalty so we've got
to try and get the relationship back
back in full swing right and I I think
that you know sometimes when somebody
says well that's extreme
my responses will yeah so what I mean it
requires a an extreme response and and
what's wrong with that you know I think
that a little extreme Behavior once in a
while is okay in order to shake things
up I mean in order to get something good
you have to you know get out of your
comfort zone and work hard and one of
the things that I thought was great
about your movie is it didn't try to
skirt around that it didn't try to say
this is super easy it's like yeah
actually this is going to be painful for
a while you're gonna have to get out of
your comfort zone it's not going to feel
good but you hit when you weather it
through like all good things in life
that you know you can place value on it
will be worth it and it will transform
your life and there is you know our
society is now we're we're rigged to try
to avoid anything uncomfortable
everything about our culture is about
being comfortable making things easy and
immediate and we've lost touch with the
value of of uh you know hard work and
getting out of your comfort zone and
trying something new and pushing
yourself and and and uh you know I think
that it's worth exploring and if you
want to call that extreme you know I
don't know I I don't know what to say to
that I mean I think that it's it's uh
like I said you know I would question
what the mat what's what's wrong with
the little extreme Behavior once in a
while and you know I think one of the
most underused words and um and things
is perspective
I think we we tend to have don't use
perspective enough you know not only the
word but also the actual action of it so
if I sort of put things in this I I use
perspective a lot as a very powerful
tool you know I use it to go like time
travel I go forward 20 years in time in
in a perspective I go what's my life
going to be like it's 67 because I'm 47
today and I really think about
at 67 what am I going to be able to do
where am I going to be able to go what
are my knees going to be like what are
my shoulders going to be like um
how many pounds am I going to be am I
going to be on medication am I going to
have all my hair you know I think about
these things and maybe I'm crazy but I
actually use it I don't think about all
the time but every now and then I'll
think about that
and I sort of pretend I'm in the future
kind of thing and I'll go you know what
I really want to go sailing today I want
to go for a hike or I want to go and
ride my bike along the beach when I'm 67
I want to be doing that and so I go I
know that the choices I'm going to make
today and now I flash back in time to
real time and I go I know the choices
I'm going to make today are going to set
up me being able to do that in the
future so I I use perspective a lot in
that way I also use it to cover off the
question that you're talking now about
about extremely extreme and I look at
say
from when I was 20 to 40 are those 20
years of my life
and I look at what you know I did 20
years where I basically smashed my body
effectively you know I would say I did
the crime so to speak right and I paid
the penalty in terms of of being sick
and being overweight and being I was a
pretty happy guy I'm not I don't want to
paint the picture that I was depressed
because I'm a generally a happy person
but I you know wasn't happy about being
on medication and I wasn't happy about
you know having a size 44 jeans or not
been able to go in and buy clothes it
wasn't good you know but you know when I
looked at that and I thought okay you
know really what is uh two years is what
I decided it would take to decide
whether I was going to be able to get my
life back on track I mean I'd done 20
years of of of crime I thought two years
in sort of prison so to speak to use the
analogy like to be sentenced to two
years of hard labor which is plants only
and to see if I could to see if I could
get well terrible Joe well yeah but but
you've got to remember coming from the
position where I was that did sound
terrible and if we talked to average
Americans out there today you said
you're going to eat plants for the next
two years from their diet they would
think that I know no I know and I
thought that I really did I really did
well this goes back to the issue of
perspective right correct and and to
sort of piggyback on what you're saying
you know take a step back and have a
larger sort of broader perspective on
the way that we're leading our lives or
what's normal now and you know when you
look at men in their 40s and their 50s
and it's it's all about erectile
dysfunction and Viagra and how many
medications you're on and the stent that
you're having put in or the heart attack
you just had or the bypass surgery you
had and the Obesity and the diabetes and
all this sort of thing that's normal
that doesn't nobody blinks an eye when
guys our age talk about this kind of
stuff and it's completely radical if you
say I'm gonna wake up in the morning
instead of having bacon and eggs or
pancakes for breakfast I'm gonna have a
green juice yep you're like a pariah
yeah so that's a weird perspective shift
I think where there's a there's a lot of
work that needs to be done very much I
mean you ask any any person from around
the world who comes to America and
spends a week on vacation you know what
one of the and you're in a hotel okay
they've got to be in a hotel you know
what one of the big things they're going
to tell you that they just cannot
believe about America
is how much advertising on television
there is for pharmaceutical drugs see we
don't have that in other parts of the
world but if you're in America that's
normal right but that's so unknown
that's so not normal
ideations and you know possible heart
failure and I mean can you imagine you
imagine us advertising green juice and
of course the the real bad side effects
are you're gonna feel great you're gonna
like lose a few pounds I mean you know I
mean it's just it's it's it's I don't
know but but I think yeah perspective is
is a really powerful tool so 20 years I
smashed myself I say to myself I'm gonna
do two years in like you know Plant
World and that's my prison so to speak I
end up saying I'm going to do solitary
confinement for the first two months
which was 60 days of juice and then it I
only I was I was let out on good
behavior after 90 more days so in five
months I've got my body back I didn't
know you need to do the two and then you
had Stockholm syndrome because you fell
in love with your captor that's right
exactly I like that I like it
so I mean that's the other thing too
that that is a big part of my story I
mean like yourself I smashed my body
forever drugs alcohol window diet I mean
you know McDonald's I mean I I'm right
with you with all that kind of stuff and
uh and the amazing thing that I think
you know you the point is made in your
movie but also I think it needs to be
hammered home even more
in a more hardcore way is just how
unbelievably resilient the human body is
when you begin to treat it right in a
very very short period of time 20 years
of abuse and you're still alive you know
and then within a matter of days
weeks but really in a matter of days I
mean in a in one week of doing a juice
fast you can completely change how you
feel and reset your trajectory after 20
years of abuse the body responds when
you start treating it right it's it's
amazing you know and so for people that
are out there that are struggling or
they think they can't do it or uh it's
not for them you know I urge all of you
to try something like this like just a
week it's a week out of your life
you know we'll refund you your misery
you can go back to eating McDonald's you
know what I mean but like to just you
owe it to yourself to try something new
and different and to pay attention to
how your body responds to how you treat
it yeah now I I couldn't say a bit of
myself you know I mean I saw the the
most the sort of the most emotional
moment in your movie for me that gave me
like chills when I saw it is when you're
kind of um sort of experiencing the
success of this journey for yourself and
you're enjoying that run on the beach on
Bandai and then you cut to Phil and he's
running in the snow and I was like he's
running you know like incredible what a
miracle it is for that guy to be doing
that like look I have Goosebumps yeah no
I'm just remembering it it's amazing
that a guy like that could experience
such a dramatic change but it all
started because he you know in recovery
they say sobriety isn't for people who
need it it's for people that want it and
you know you you encounter that guy in
the truck stop you had a conversation
with him like you had with a lot of
people on your cross-country Journey
350. but somebody something just stuck
with him and one day he picked up the
phone he was ready you know you have to
be ready you've got to have that moment
you've got to be open and you know I'm
sure you get this wish but I get so many
husbands and wives or Partners saying
you know my partner the person I love
the most just isn't making the change
what can I do
to to get them you know it's like you
can lead the horse to water you can't
make a drink
and my answer you know I don't have all
the answers but I think you know you
just got to be patient you know and and
by pushing that person is actually
making it worse by actually pushing them
you're actually driving them further
away I couldn't agree with you mark what
what I say to them is listen
okay let's just say it's a it's a wife
of a husband and they're trying to get
their husband to do it I say look you
know what you can do if you're the
nutritional gatekeeper of the house like
you're the one who goes and gets all the
the food start making healthier food he
doesn't eat it that's fine like he's not
gonna eat it like he can do whatever but
just keep at it and lead by example
don't don't push it like don't you know
it's like don't tell people what to do
okay we go back to that you know but I
know it's hard I know it's really tough
and I I it's sometimes it's easy just to
say it but but really it's um you know
people have to realize they're making it
worse by pushing people sometimes
because if you're not ready you're not
ready right absolutely
um I experienced that firsthand actually
my wife who is who was the nutritional
gatekeeper in our house she wrote a post
on Mind Body green about our experience
with this and it was a it was a really
interesting thing that happened which
was she was always much healthier than
me and for a long time she's like try
this why don't you do this why aren't
you eating like this like you know she
was always trying to get me on a better
path than I was on and the more she did
that the more I resisted I was like I
don't want any of that and then one day
like honestly like in a on a very kind
of deep spiritual level she just made
peace with it and she just let it go
she's like I love him the way he is he's
got his own path and it's none of my
business I'm gonna she still would make
the healthy meals and she would lead by
example and do all those things that you
said but she really let it go and I
think some when that happened like she
didn't announce it to me she didn't say
anything to me but I knew it I could
sense it and then suddenly there was no
push on me and and that made me go
oh wait like maybe I should change
because like I have to do it for my like
she's not pushing me to do it like this
is on me now yeah and it made me really
look at myself and go you know I maybe
you know I don't like the way I feel and
I would like to feel better the way
she's doing and maybe there is something
to this but I had to come to that on on
in my own way
I couldn't agree more you've gotta
you've got to arrive at that position
yourself if anyone who's pushed there
it's just not gonna happen it's such a
such a personal thing that I feel that
it's almost like you want to own it
yourself and you've got to own it
because these changes I mean you know
I'm sure you have too rich but one of
the things that we're very lucky about
in our positions is we get to speak to a
lot of smart people a lot of people that
know a lot more than you and I putting
together right and I spoke to a guy
called Professor Brian one sink who
wrote that book careless and Mindless
eating mm-hmm
and he and his researchers
you know they've been studying food
behavior for 25 years so you just
imagine that that's been your life your
life's work is food Behavior not
necessarily healthy food just how people
behave around food
and what I learned from uh from him in
my in my three or four hours is just get
you know how many decisions we make
about food every day just the average
person over 200. now if you've got over
200 choices and decisions on food every
day and you're just going to rely on
self-discipline
good luck with that good luck with that
good luck with the time that you're
stressed or you're in a hurry or
someone's shouting at you you've gotta
like you know you're tired you didn't
sleep very well good luck at trying to
choose the the Cucumber over the
chocolate bar then you know then what is
the solution then well I think I think
being aware aware of that is really is
really important but but here's where
the I'm saying that in connection to it
coming from within so if you and
yourself have arrived at that point
rather than using out the the example
you said with your wife is if your
wife's trying to push you well the
minute she's looking the other direction
that's my point yeah because you've got
200 choices therefore it's not gonna it
has to come from within because when
it's coming from within then those 200
choices that you make there's a much
more of a of an internal assistance
that's helping you guide that way so
when you say what's the solution I mean
I'll tell you what I really think and
and what I believe is that when you do a
reboot and you feel so amazing and
you're loving the view and you're
putting the fuel in that makes you feel
fabulous those 200 choices are a lot
easier to make yeah and I would add to
that that you know if you're making
unhealthy food choices or you feel like
you have these food addictions or you're
powerless and that elevator is going
down you don't have to hit some crazy
bottom like I did or like Joe did where
you have a big Reckoning moment where
your doctor tells you you're going to
die I mean you can get off that elevator
at any moment you can make that decision
and what's great about doing one of
these juice fasts or the reboot or
whatever version of it that you want to
do is that it involves putting a lot of
energy into a shift right and like we
were talking about before that number of
days or the amount of energy or just the
process of going to the store and buying
these foods and preparing to do this
number of days where you're going to do
this kind of radical seemingly radical
thing creates that momentum for you to
then set in motion a new way of doing
things and I think it's really powerful
yeah and I'd also add to that that a lot
of of people come to me and say you know
I don't think I need to do already but I
think my diet's pretty good and I go
well that's fantastic I mean that's
awesome but then I just say but you know
what what's really cool and I had a lot
of people do this so you might want to
try
is that one of the great ways to find
out just how good your diet is is to try
a reboot because if you can do a reboot
and really cruise through it without any
pain or any suffering or any withdrawals
then the chances are that what you are
doing is that right but you know what
this is a great way to challenge
yourself to find out if what you are
doing is it's like a calibrator because
if you get so used to feeling lousy you
don't know that you're you don't you
don't know that you feel well yeah well
even if people think they're on a great
diet this is why my point is is that I
meet a lot of like really fit looking
healthy looking people that say you know
my diet's perfect or I don't say they
don't use the word perfect they say my
my diet's really good I go well then you
probably don't need to do a reboot but
I'll tell you what you could do just for
a bit of like science experiment on
yourself is try it and if you sort of
don't experience any withdrawals or any
pain then the odds are that you are on a
really good diet but if you experience
withdrawals if you're incredibly tired
if you're agitated if you're angry then
you probably didn't realize it but there
was probably something in the way you
were living that was too much because I
I know from now the hundreds of
thousands of people that have done this
is that the more pain you go through in
those first three or four days of of
juicing or switching to plants if you'll
go if you go through massive pain that
means that you were doing something in
your diet that was really giving you a
lot of grief you know whether it's the
caffeine whether it's the sugar whether
it's the salt whether it's the fat but
you know you just don't you don't suffer
withdrawals on juicing if your diet is
is in great shape to start with you
don't right I mean when I did it I was I
couldn't move I was on the couch for a
good two and a half maybe three days
like I literally felt like I was back in
rehab like detoxing off opiates or
something like that I don't know I
believe you me I I mean I stupidly
didn't even let the cameras in I was
feeling that bad who am I make because I
never made a movie before I'm like you
guys are staying out there that's the
good stuff I know but I didn't know that
you see I never made a movie before
right like honestly I uh and when I got
to the last day you know you start to
feel better with each Progressive day
until you just feel amazing I get to the
last day and I tell my wife like I'm
just you know like I hadn't seen your
move your movie hadn't come out yet and
I'm like I want to keep going like I you
know like this there's no reason to stop
like like a good alcoholic I'm just like
this is I don't need food anymore I'm
just gonna because I feel so good we get
a lot of so I understand the whole like
I'm gonna go for 30. I'm gonna go for 60
like I was if had I seen your movie
before doing it I probably would have
gone much longer I wanted to you know
well you know on day 60
um I wasn't actually too far from where
we are now we're in LA and I was in San
Diego when I went up in the air in the
balloon to to uh break my 60 days uh and
I'm watching that thinking why we'll
just keep why don't you keep going I
thought maybe you weren't gonna take a
bite and say I'm going to do another 30.
you know what you know if I had if I had
the budget I probably would have but
like having a film crew and having all
of that done it was kind of like the
logistics I mean I've learned a lot now
I actually knowing now I probably could
have because I could have just said go
and take a break guys and we'll just
catch you in but I didn't think that I
was filming every day I mean I've
learned a lot about making movies since
then let me tell you so so I was feeling
so good I really was thinking about
doing 100 days like there was but then I
started doing the finances of another 40
Days of the crew and I'm going to get
broke did you self-finance the movie or
how did it how did it work yeah in the
beginning I um the whole idea was to to
to
um
uh to do it myself but I started telling
some mates of mine in Australia who were
who are just uh good buddies in the
finance world and stock breaking and
future as well where I came from and
some others from Investment Banking
world and uh they all say oh this is
great you know we'll we'll have a piece
of this so a bunch of mates uh also put
some money in and they I think in the
end I was like 75 and they were like 25
right of the movie and did you have any
idea at the time that it would become
the phenomenon that it has become it
depends what you mean by at the time
because it took well I would 2006 to
2011 right before was released so when
Phil rang me up okay see how long how
long in real time was it from when you
met filter when he called you
uh I met Phil in um
November of 2007 and he called me in May
of 2008.
so and and I was and the film the first
film I made which no one will ever see
uh was was actually my journey across
America
and six people that did a 10-day
reboot and that's where xiong who um the
the one lady that's in the movie that
does right her juicing with her coffee
and her husband out in uh in Iowa
believe it or not and there's the Iowa
connection again so
um and we were on time on budget with
the movie to be my journey Arc the
beginning to the end and then these six
people who were juicing while I was
doing mine so so my 60 days was broken
into six ten days with other people
doing it so for the whole journey I was
talking to these six average Americans
so that was the first movie but then
when Phil called up
I sit at the producer Stacy off and I
said Stacy we're going to get over and
film this guy she said to me Joe you are
insane we've got a movie that's nearly
nearly finished and you want to break
out the crew again and shoot stuff I
mean
this is unheard of but we didn't know
you've got to remember you don't know he
could flake after a day correct yeah so
you got it you've got to go back to all
we've got is a voicemail all we've got
is a voicemail a guy saying I need help
okay
so it was like
what do you do here and I thought
I'm instant immediately I've got to go
over and do it I mean there was no doubt
in my mind that I had to shoot it the
question was how would it fit into the
movie and so I thought that this could
be in the credits so when the credits
are running there could be this three
minute four minute vignette
of Phil right that was kind of the
thinking so that's how I convinced her
to agree for me to spend my own money to
to make to get the crew out again right
so then we went we went to Sheldon Iowa
in um in in it took about a month to get
that planned so it was Mother's Day in
May and then we didn't get there until
you know just around Fourth of July just
before it was like late June right it
took about four weeks five weeks to plan
organize get everything set crew me back
to the US and work out what we were
going to do get doctors organized to to
monitor him
so when we got there I thought 10 days
will will be enough for Phil he'll do 10
days and that's all we planned on right
because you were yeah you're there and
then you're kind of like all right I
gotta go and yeah well well I only I I
made a conscious decision that it's no
good having Joe fly in and be this being
a trainer maybe you know no no otherwise
that's like that's like um that's not
real I mean I can't do that for
everybody you know but coming in and
spending the day before getting him you
know meeting him again seeing where he
lives
um getting the doctor to look and see
whether this is possible going to a
supermarket
cranking him out showing him the first
juice this is what you do this is how it
works and then saying right I'm going to
leave you with a sound guy a a camera
guy and a producer there's going to be
three people they're going to stay here
for the next 10 days and you want to
quit you quit you want to do anything
you know these guys are not telling you
what to do all they are is to capture
your thoughts and what you're doing
right no one's telling you what to do
here Phil
and so I said you know I'll come back in
um in 10 days or I'll meet you or we'll
talk then I didn't actually plan to
actually come back because it was like
you know what just we'll just talk on
the phone but then he got to day 10 he
said I want to keep going and I'm like
really
three thousand five hundred dollars a
day for my camera crew out there and
accommodation by the lake however you
look like a really nice like Lake
accommodations there yeah like a nice
vacation how long do you want to go for
so so it was caught up your buddies in
finance yeah well well this is where it
got to and you know now the economic
crisis is happening too now in 2008 and
so I'm like I'm like okay well we'll
keep them going you know like we'll keep
the cameras going and let's see where
this goes but and then of course the we
didn't know he was going to keep going
and we didn't know the doctor would let
him we didn't know the results and we
had no idea you know and so it went
another 60 days and he wanted to keep
going and I said mate you're really
sending me a break we have to stop and
so that was it he went 61. and then he
kept going afterwards so we couldn't
finish the film because like he wanted
to get into that T-shirt and it took
another nine months and he was there
running in that final final shot so it's
like now we've got to we've got we've
got like this whole new film versus the
other film and so we had to then start
again right so all the work on the first
film was like new editors new team come
in so all that money is sunk and so now
the budget is really blowing out so now
enter into my my uh my bank managers
having a coronary heart attack so so you
know it was it was it was a it was a
very interesting time
um because and you asked me when did I
know
I felt that my journey was equivalent to
the Forest Gump running across America
and people just coming along and
following and Phil was the first person
to follow he was really the first person
who said you know what
I liked what that guy did and I saw what
he did I want to try that and so it was
kind of like the When Harry Met Sally a
moment you know I'll have what she's
having and that to me was when I knew at
that point I thought wow you're calling
up and I bloke I mean no one really
cares about a rich white guy from
Australia you know and who cares about
Joe but a Phil a bloke who's 430 pounds
who's effectively living in the back of
his truck that you know needs the TV on
at night when he was sleeping in those
first four or five days by the lake
because he couldn't not sleep without
noise because he's used to the trucks on
the highway and noise
um you know that's that's true
who's doing a community night at the
Natural Foods Market yeah and everyone's
showing up and he's explaining to them
what killed 30 days later yeah I mean
it's incredible so I knew then that we
had something
um I didn't think it was going to be as
big as it is because you just don't I
but I also get the sense that just from
getting an idea of the way your mind
works and and watching the movie and and
reading up a little bit on you I mean
I get the sense that when you made the
movie it wasn't just hey I'm gonna make
a movie and go back to my life and
finance that there was a there's a
long-term plan here like to start this
movement only seven months later that we
remember honestly if if Phil had made
the phone call
I reckon I would have gone just got that
movie out because I wouldn't have put
the effort in I wouldn't have and it
would have come out in 2000 and um and
it would have come out at the end of
2008.
and that wouldn't have been a Netflix so
you know what I mean so it would have
been just so it would have been an
interesting movie but it would not have
captured the I mean the emotional
connection that you develop with Phil
and that story and the relationship
between the two of you guys is what
really elevates the whole so I think
that there was a lot of
um uh you know I I you can use the word
luck and I believe in luck I mean I have
you know rule number two in my life is
Lady Luck follows a person of action so
you've got to be doing the things to
bring it on but I think that there was a
there was like a an alignment of the
planet so to speak where a lot of
sequences and a lot of events have led
to this story or or of sharing getting
out there so you know very fortunate
with social media Twitter Facebook
Instagram these things to be in their
Prime when the movie Broke very
fortunate to have Hulu Netflix Amazon
Apple iTunes all of these things really
firing at the time when the content came
out so you know that that's you can't
underestimate the distribution platform
I mean my movie you know I mean here's a
crazy thing which we're in Hollywood
world right now right we're in La where
two miles from Fox Studios we're three
four miles from Universal you know all
the big movie houses right now I know
people in media so I was very fortunate
I got in to see the heads of all this
Studios I gave screenings when the movie
was finished in
2010 when I finally finished it I I did
like two months out here of screenings
to all the big Studio Executives trying
to see whether they would buy the movie
and distribute it through movie theaters
you know what I learned
they'd bring 200 people along all their
offices or their people to do the the
judgments
every single time I did a screening
always inundated with what's the recipe
for the green juice where do I buy a
juicer like these were the questions it
wasn't about the movie it was about what
I what do I need to do is there a plan I
mean this was the top Executives I'm
like thinking this is really good
they're actually going to want to do the
movie they're going to want to buy it
and then I'd say well here's that you've
got to get cucumber you've got to get
celery you've got to get and I talked
for half an hour about the Whole Health
side of things and then at the end I'd
say and what about the movie what do you
think oh no no you're not a Hugh Jackman
or Russell Crowe you know we don't know
how to Market this I think it's a great
movie though but that recipe thanks for
that see ya and it was like right okay
so these guys in Hollywood don't
understand
that you know I mean whether what that
sorry let me rephrase that they didn't
understand how to Market something that
wasn't cookie cutter for how they
normally do a film which I understand I
mean I get that that's business so the
power of the streaming the power of
Netflix and the and and the model that
we have now that if you can make content
that's good enough it will rise to the
top and people will share questions I
mean they're very fortunate to have that
yeah I mean it's it's doing incredibly
well online on Netflix and I think you
know Forks Over Knives is still like one
of the most downloaded documentaries or
stream documentaries on Netflix I mean
there is a an interest and a movement
and a a Zeitgeist moment that we're
experiencing right now where people
finally are really you know wanting to
take a look at this and do something
different so absolutely and and I and I
believe the wave of
like like it's easy for you and I
because we're living and breathing this
all the time
to get a little bit um complacent I
think to thinking that this movement is
actually bigger than it is because it's
actually really still small when you
really look at the the the 316 million
Americans and you take another sort of
800 million people living in the western
world and you add it all up to a billion
people that are you know live in the way
that we talked about earlier in the fun
part of town so it still isn't it it's
in its infancy and I am hugely uh
optimistic about how big the tsunami
this this this this wave of awareness
and and thirst and hunger to use the
puns or information
for the rich content of food to put in
their body I mean I I just you know I
think there are
now a very very smart friend of mine
who's a very bright boy he he told me he
said Joe there are four big stories in
the world today in in the in the in
terms of economics he said that's the
rise of China the rise of the internet
the American independence on energy
story
and the rise of health and wellness and
you know when you have a when I have a
guy like that who's a very smart guy you
know tell me that those four things and
he puts Health and Wellness in that
category
and I know who he talks to I know the
smart people who control billions of
dollars when I hear that you know that's
very
um optimistic to me that the top end of
town is thinking that way right so is
this your full-time thing now are you
still doing private Equity or no no no
this is my full-time this is your full
time
I have to um I think that the
opportunity like I'm I'm you know John
Mackey um wrote a book called conscious
capital I don't know whether you read it
or yeah
but I I really think that that he's the
way he describes
um his business is something that I
would like to think that I can model my
my company on and in that I think that
you can't just be too extreme of all you
worry about is the customer because then
suppliers and your staff and investors
are going to be left out and you can't
be all about making money which is just
for the investors because then your
customers are going to be not looked
after so it's about finding this this
this this very
um this balance in inside of your of the
the company side of things as to doing
good but also valuing it and ensuring
that that you can create some kind of uh
Revenue stream that can keep the dream
alive and so that's what I've been
working very hard on for the last few
years and you know I give a lot of stuff
away for free
um on the website and also in real life
like time when I go and talk of places
and and and so on and you know I don't
know I don't know how much I'll be able
to keep that up because it's not really
efficient to go to a town and speak to
200 people and you can be making
television and making movies that can be
reaching hundreds of thousands of people
but I still really like to to press the
Flesh and to touch people and to hear
them because I think I learn so much
more when I do that so
that the balance now is this is my
full-time job
um and you know and I like to think of
it that you know I'm very excited about
it I mean I'm I'm loving it I don't
actually think about it which is a job
it's just what I do it's just like my
life so I don't really think about days
off or work days to me everything is you
know it's a Saturday now and we're doing
this right right and I don't this is not
hard labor I mean people dig in holes
out you know and and laying down you
know tar on the roads that's hard work
what I do is not hard work what I do is
um I try my best to take complicated
things that are difficult so for some
people to understand try to make them
simple for people to understand try to
put it in a logical way try to do that
in in storytelling be it in movies or TV
stuff that I'm trying to work on to try
and work out ways that can make fun TV
um stuff for the internet whether it's
short stuff like what you're doing here
with podcasts and and books and and and
and events and we just did a fantastic
thing last month we did a 200 people
came and did Camp reboot up in um in uh
about two hours three hours north of uh
of New York City in a place called
Rhinebeck at the at the Optimum Health
uh the uh Amiga Institute and 200 people
came in Juiced with me for six days and
it was awesome it was unbelievable from
all over the country and just to see
those people's changes in their lives
just in those five six days and just
incredible so you know that's you know
so what I'm doing is I'm doing that I
mean I look at my company as a media
company you know I create content
we have an e-commerce platform for our
our stuff on on online and we also do um
do Licensing in terms of of the brand
with uh with corporations and and and
people who want to associate with our
values and I think that you know that's
the model that I'm working on
um I'm enjoying it it's uh it's it's
working so far it's it's all you know
I've got 15 16 employees now we just
hired someone this week oh that's great
so you know 16 mouths to feed
or juices to make yeah so I mean that's
one good thing about Wherever I Go I
mean wherever I go I get free juice so
that's the the expenses are pretty cheap
on the juice let me ask you this did
Brazil did they uh did they pay for that
branded entertainment in in uh yeah you
know what kind of deal did you it's a
really good question and thanks for
asking because it gives me a chance to
to um always talk about that so so the
interesting thing about this and this is
like people do not believe this I
honestly they I tell the story and I
think that people don't believe it well
they don't doubled their revenue after
the movie oh no that I think people
believe no I think people believe that
no no no no the story I'm going to tell
you is that the night before we started
shooting in New York
when I had no idea how to make a movie
and I'd never done this before we were
doing a checklist of all the stuff we
had and needed to make the movie you
know we got all this stuff
we'd forgotten to buy the juices this is
this is a this is how organized team
reboot and Joe crosswise the night
before countdown all right for to start
in this so I raced up to a store
um on on on Houston and uh Broadway uh
Creighton Barrel store and I went in and
I didn't know the first thing about
machines
but the Breville brand I recognize from
Australia
so I just went up and bought the juicer
that I knew the brand I mean I'm like
one of those guys I'm a brand guy I go
okay that must be all right I know that
brand I don't know I don't know these
names but I know that one so I just
bought the machine out of it and then I
was walking to the counter thought I
better buy two because what if it breaks
and I'm right in the middle of Omaha or
Nebraska or Kansas I need a machine
because I mean you know this is not
going to be pretty if I have got a
machine so I went back and bought two so
I bought two of them and um
that was it honestly that was how I that
was how I got that machine it was no I
didn't talk to the company I didn't know
any endorsement did nothing
and then
about so that was like
October of 07 and then around uh June
July of 08 when we were going out to um
to fill because I'd been in the edit
room for a few months I was posting on
social media on my own
uh page as my own page I didn't have any
company page or any public profile page
I was posting photos from the edit room
of me standing in front of the big
screen with me behind the movie screen
with juicing with me like right because
we'd hired this room to do the color
correct
and so
a friend of mine then shared that photo
and someone from Breville saw that photo
of me with a juicer
and so they then reached out via
Facebook to me what are you doing we
work at this company and I said oh well
we're doing this movie but we're not
going to show you until it's finished
but I'm not showing anybody until it's
finished and they said well if you need
any help with machines let us know and
we'll we'll just give you some because I
was buying them at this stage right so
when we went out to do the fill sort of
community reboot you know how we went
out there to Iowa after he was sort of
in his in his in his in his mindset we
needed six machines so we bought them
actually uh Breville gave us those six
machines for the for the filming when
Phil was doing it so that was how they
got involved via the social platform and
then um it wasn't until until uh the
movie was finished it was done it was
out I didn't have any commercial
relationship with them or any juice
company at all when the movie Broke on
Netflix in 2011 I had every juice
extractor company in the world wanting
to sign me right to do a deal and while
some of the financial numbers were
better from other companies I just felt
that I had to keep it real that it would
look kind of very strange is that I used
a Breville juicer in the movie and now
I'm using XYZ juicer so I just felt that
the whole idea to keep it real and keep
it transparent and I've got to be honest
Rich if that juicer had broken like on
day 15 I probably wouldn't have done the
deal because why am I going to endure
something that's going to break in the
middle yeah and you'd probably want that
in the movie too like yeah it broke that
would create a crisis moment in the
movie it would have been but what I'm
saying is I wouldn't endorse something
that it broke after 15 days so the fact
that I didn't need the second machine
the fact that it it lasted and the fact
that I just felt that to be true to the
fans and the and the people who wanted
to really do this is they're going to
spend their hard-earned money I mean
money is really hard to come by that
they may as well I may as well make stay
true to the values so while it wasn't
the the most lucrative deal at the time
like to to actually sign up there's much
bigger money being offered by
infomercial world and all that right I
just felt you know what
keep it real you know what's amazing is
you're you're kind of recounting these
dates like oh and you know early 2007
this was going on and I'm thinking what
was I doing at that time and you know
we're essentially the same age and we
kind of started this thing at the same
time like you did your 60 days like
literally like at the same time that I
was starting to do this and then kind of
getting back into being fit and you're
making a documentary and I'm training
for Ultraman you know like and here we
are like sitting here talking about it a
couple years later it's it's it's crazy
my moment happened when I turned 40
right that's exact my mine happened
literally like the day or two days
before my 40th birthday Mom was a day of
because I went out the night before and
I went crazy the night before so the
next morning I mean you know I was in
real bad shape I had
that's a good place to start though well
it was but you know it was something
about it was something about having a
four it like like you know something
about having a four at the front of my
birth my age like a three I could handle
it was close to a two forties a big yeah
I mean Four's close to five you know I
mean you know it's like hey get up there
it's so trade you know it's that oh turn
40 you know what's what you know what is
my life about kind of moment but you
know it happens it's true it happened to
both of us and I think another thing
that I wanted to kind of talk about a
little bit I know we're going along I
don't want to take you too long but but
there's the other kind of thing that
resonates with your story that that I
relate to a lot is this idea of kind of
um
you know being a successful guy you know
you kind of did everything that you
thought uh would make you happy you know
you're pursuing wealth you're you're
successful you're making money you're
kind of adhering to all of society's
rules about like what you're supposed to
do as a man to be successful to be
respected to feel good about yourself we
both did that I was a lawyer and uh and
I played that out and it literally led
me to like a spiritual crisis of you
know I did all the things that I thought
I was supposed to do and not only am I
terribly unhealthy I'm really like
unhappy with these choices that I've
made and where I'm at with my life and
then for you to be sitting here and say
you know oh it's Saturday like I don't
consider what I what I'm doing work now
you know it's just what I do you know
that's a that's a beautiful thing and
that's a long way from you know kind of
doing something that is you know the
more traditional route yeah
no no I mean
I know I'm sure you do too I know a lot
of people a lot of money and I you know
most of them aren't as happy as people
who have got less to be honest I mean
hey we're in Hollywood right now how
many like really rich people I know that
are you know really not happy people a
lot you know there's a lot
um I think I think also uh
you know sticking with the theme of
keeping it simple because I've given
this a lot of thought this this subject
that you've talked about and
you know I think that when it comes down
to it
we are jugglers that's what we are each
and every one of us is a juggler
and we're predominantly juggling five
things
we juggle
family and friends we juggle love
we juggle our career we juggle our
health and we juggle self so and for
self that could be your a lot of things
but it's a really your yourself so how
you view yourself your whether it's your
religion your spirituality your self
and so if you think about juggling those
five things
what I was doing
is that I was completely dropping one or
two of the balls I can I dropped them
for a long time so I found it easier to
juggle three things than five things
Rich right so there's three things being
I was juggling family and friends I was
juggling Korea and um I was juggling uh
uh self I think you know I was doing
that the the things that I wasn't uh
doing was health and love okay I was
like they were the ones they're the
balls I dropped I I just like not gonna
worry about those and let them Wither on
the vine over there okay so
you know and and if you do that
I think what happens is is that you you
end up with a crisis because you can't
ignore those other balls that you have
to juggle and to be a human to to
achieve happiness to achieve
um success in the terms of see to me
success is keeping all five balls in the
air that's what success is to me keeping
them up there and and doing your best
you can and balancing that that effort
in all five of them and not just
focusing on what it's easy to focus on
one and I was you know the career one I
mean I was going home with that I was
good at that and so I give myself the
pat on the back for being good at the
career and that's what I was focused on
well and and culturally that's really
what's prioritized sure sure if you're
doing good in your career then you're
doing good and it appears on the outside
that you are successful that you are so
it's it's an illusion okay it's a
complete illusion it's nothing more than
illusion and we can't cheat ourselves as
to our own happiness I mean I I really
do believe that that that the happier I
am I find the more useful I am the
happier I am is probably the thing I've
learned the most out of this whole
journey the more useful the more happy
when I feel useless is when I'm least
happy
and so I think that that juggling of
those five balls now I really you know
I'm not by the way I'm far from perfect
okay but I'm trying is what I'm trying
to do and having the awareness of trying
to do it and and you know working on it
and and just putting the effort in which
actually means you're keeping busy
trying to do it and being useful
actually propels the momentum of
Happiness forward so
that's the way I look at it now I mean
you know if someone had told me that I'd
be getting up in front of 2 000 people
talking about bowel movements six years
ago I would have said they've got rocks
yeah but now it's like one of my
favorite subjects you know what goes in
must come out and so just having this
this this uh I mean I I mean like I'm
blessed I'm very very lucky to be 47
years of age
um and to have this view that for the
next 20 years I feel like I'm going to
be making content and and sharing
stories and and and meeting people like
yourself that are doing incredible
things out there in the world
um and and the great thing about what we
do I'm now putting my business hat on is
that you and I have no competitors that
that's the incredible thing about this
it's very unusual in in in the business
side of things every single person out
there that is trying to share or spread
the word I am only too happy to promote
in a UI too yeah absolutely which is
unusual when you think about it but
because it's in the infants see of this
of this um this tsunami of of awareness
that's coming that we're all just trying
to help each other get as much of the
word out as possible because it's going
to in the end there is so much uh
to be done that we that no one person
can do at all oh there's no way it has
to be done together as a team and I
think that the the happiness quotient
um really is a function of of just doing
something that's of service really I
mean you're of service and you know no
doubt you get crazy emails from people
all over the world or phone calls or
people that you have conversations with
who tell you how you've touched their
lives and and you know that you're on
the right path and that this is what
you're supposed to be doing and it keeps
you directed and motivated
look I mean I'm blessed it's not a day
that goes by that I can't go on Twitter
or Facebook and with every I mean
there's probably not even
be really honest it's probably not a two
hour period that doesn't go by
I don't get a note from somebody
thanking me now just think about that
every two hours someone I don't even
know in the world from somewhere like in
Iceland or from Dubai or from Argentina
or from Omaha Nebraska or from
Philadelphia sending me a note saying
you've touched my I mean that's that is
that that that's worth you know more
than any houses or planes or boats you
can't go back to private Equity
well I mean you could but you you know
I'm not going back there you take that
skill set that you have taken for you uh
yeah you I I directed in a exopriate
direction exactly I think I think that
that
um we have to live in the world today
Bound by the rules we have okay there
are rules there are taxes to pay there's
rent to pay there's mouths to feed okay
so we can't be completely off in the
Pixies and believing in fairies at the
bottom of the garden we have to keep it
real we have to make sure that we're
diligent about the way that we spend our
money our time our effort and the
business that we're building because if
you if you can't pay the bills you can't
send the message out right so if there
is a balance so I I try to keep it um in
check and I'm fortunate that I've got
the business skills that I did in the
past life you know yeah that I can bring
forward now and use those in this this
current trajectory of spreading as much
of the of of my story and other people's
stories as possible because I think it's
story driven is uh is is what I is the
area that I'm focused on in trying to um
to promote this uh this uh
world of feeling better looking better
living longer and being happier I mean
and really it's when you think about it
which it's pretty crazy that you know
we've got a like if you wear back like 2
000 years and you said like what do you
do oh like we're in the we're in the
business of promoting people to eat more
food delicious it's like look at you and
go so
that's all there is to eat isn't it what
else is
I think that's what I'm supposed to be
doing yeah exactly you're creating a
business out of this how does that work
exactly I I don't get that uh-huh well
so I think it's I think it's um it's one
of the one of the one of the things that
I'm constantly reminded of also is that
is that there's a
multi-billion Dollar business behind
what we do I mean the the farmers
agriculture the fruit and vegetable
people they're all out there I mean they
want they they're happy for what you and
I are doing they're very excited about
this so harnessing that power and right
now it's like herding cats all these
people out there in the in the space of
uh of the fruit and visual but I I'm
confident that that they will unite and
that they'll be able to get that message
out in a more powerful way that can can
be uh as strong as some of these other
corporations that are you know pushing
water and sugar and salt and fat so I
I'm optimistic about the future I'm glad
to hear that I mean that was was one of
the questions I wanted to ask you is if
you you know if that if that optimism
ever gets tempered you know and someone
just watching the conversations that you
have with these people in the in the in
the documentary and they're just you
know you just sit there and you tell
them here's your path to becoming a
completely different improved person and
they're they just say thank you but no
thank you you know and it's like easy to
get worn out like you said you got 300
you met 350 people
yeah and so how many of those people are
just sort of like dismissive does that
ever wear you down no it never weighs me
down I don't get worn down with it I
think I I think that that uh what I the
way I look at it is is that the people
who are like
50 and 60 years of age now
if they're going to continue down the
path that that we're talking about like
this
this you know 93 of their energy coming
from that Source they're not going to be
with us long
right they're not going to be around
just just the way it works I mean that's
just
biological laws of cause and effect they
won't be here
who is here is their children and what I
am noticing is how many of the younger
generation it's like you know we have
this you and I have probably we've been
around for two generations I guess we
were born one and now we're sort of
becoming the next one
and whatever what history teaches is
that every generation Rebels against
their the one before in some way you
know and I really think that the one
that this generation now is rebelling in
terms of I don't want to be like mum and
dad I don't want to be on five
medications I don't want to be obese and
sick and tired and unhappy and miserable
I don't want to be that and so I think
that the the that this new generation of
Youth that's coming through
through the power of the I mean look
there's a lot they're not perfect
there's a lot of things about them which
scares the hell out of me all right
um you talked about it earlier in this
this you know not wanting to do stuff
too tough and hard and that but
if there's anything I can see from a
positive side is I see so many young
people in their teens
and in their early Twenties that are
really interested in this you know and
momentum is really picking up for young
people who want to make this a career
whether it's Health coaching or going
into it um into the world of wellness
and preventative medicine and so I see
younger doctors really in tune with this
very much more holistic about nutrition
than older doctors so I'm I'm you know
I'm very optimistic I mean do you ever
watch a show called Mad Men of course
you know the show yeah so I like to
think about Mad Men once again using
using perspective you know I mean you go
back to Mad Men in the what is it a
1960s sort of era is when they're on
Madison Avenue and you've got the
executives and you know what are the
what are the three things on Mad Men
that really shock us today when we watch
it and that's them drinking they're
drinking the drinking the smoking and
and cutting the sick petting the
secretaries yeah you know this this
attitude towards women you know like I
mean Peggy's the the young sort of
executive and it's you know all the
secretaries are women and they're all
having an affair you know what I mean
it's like this attitude now if you think
like today they're the three things that
shock us the most and it's like yeah I
can't imagine that world today on
Madison Avenue and it just doesn't
happen
so I kind of think that well what are
people going to look back in say 50
years time on this time right now what
are people going to look at going geez
what what are they doing back there in
2010 and 2015 in can you imagine doing
that now in 2055 2060 right you know a
super big gulp and uh you know I think
it's going to be the fact that that
can you believe they let advertising be
played on television to their kids on
Saturday mornings of those sorts of
products were able to be positioned to
children can you imagine that parents
actually went out and bought this food
and gave it to their kids can you
imagine that that that's that's where I
think it's going to be in 50 years time
I hope so you know I would love nothing
more than for that to be the case and
including changing school lunches and it
really is all about the kids and it does
start with the marketing messages that
are sent over the airwaves to the
children you know they're so powerful
yeah I mean I I bring I come back to
supply and demand okay because
everything when you talk about economics
and at the end of the day the economic
shift in what we're talking about is
going to come to Bear you cannot have a
society like I think it's right now
there's I mean I I want to get these
numbers right so I'm going to go into my
memory I think it's 26 million Americans
right now a diabetic okay so the 23 or
26 but I'm gonna I'm gonna go with 26
million are diabetic and all right over
a hundred million are pre-diabetic think
about that a third of the country is
pre-diabetic
now if we continue to go at the rate
we're going
we're going to have those people will
become diabetics oh they'll get there
you can't have the economics do not
support a society where that many people
are on medication that many people are
sick it just doesn't it won't work it'll
collapse upon itself so I'm but in our
country we'll allow it to collapse
unless regulation comes in to curb that
so it really isn't so much a supply and
demand thing because unchecked you know
the fast food companies are reliant on
getting kids hooked on this stuff and
developing developing them into lifelong
customers irrespective of the long-term
you know Health ramifications of eating
that way in the same way that the
cigarette companies you know notice that
you know before laws came in to regulate
their advertising it was all about
trying to get young people interested in
smoking sure okay so
maybe in terms of that what I was I
actually started to automate supply and
demand and I went off another track so
just take that diabetes situation right
that's the reality now go to supply and
demand in the way that I wanted to talk
about it was is that I believe that you
and I are in the demand side of the
equation this is what we are we are out
sharing stories and inspiring and
educating and entertaining people to
increase demand okay
if we can increase demand the supply
will come the right now when you go into
a supermarket and you pull out five
dollars and you buy a packet of Oreo
cookies which I love by the way you buy
a packet of Oreos
you are sending a message
up the food chain through to I think
it's um Nestle that makes that product
and to make more so you are voting with
your hard-earned money
in the demand please make more the same
thing happens if you buy kale or buy
cucumber or buy broccoli you are sending
a message to the farmers please grow
more
so what I am very passionate about is
getting that message out to people that
when you spend your hard-earned dollar
you are voting for something on the
supply side so at the end of the day the
simple mathematics an equation is is
that if 50 million Americans walked into
McDonald's tomorrow and said I want a
green juice I did it the next day I did
it the next day
what do you think McDonald's will be
selling next week they would be selling
green juice so this is where the
economics of supply and demand for me
are that what we need to do is we need
to level the playing field we need to
make it easier more affordable we need
to make it time effective for people to
get energy into their body that is more
nutrient dense more nutrient Rich than
what we're doing but I believe that the
demand is coming and so because of that
the supply will will prevail
I agree with you that there's the
headwinds against us are strong
and the the wind is on our nose right
now I mean we're bashing through it
right now but I'm confident that changes
will occur when I took it when I hear
people big end of town people talk about
this when I see the investment that's
going in right now in the valley into
these sorts of
startup companies that are about
supplying healthier options and foods
and I see that happening it's early days
I mean what are we 2013
what we're talking about may not take
effect to 2020 2022 as an example just
to go out eight nine ten years but it's
coming and so I believe that I believe
that that the people in Congress will
realize the people that will see it that
what they're doing is they're actually
subsidizing corporations to make this
food that is so low in nutrients it's so
high in energy but so low in nutrients
that it's causing this effect for a 2.8
trillion dollar medical expense bill I
see it's an incredibly expensive
inefficient system that is essentially
just making us sick and driving up
Healthcare cars so from a if you're an
economist just looking at that you're
like this needs disruption this needs to
be changed we cannot continue down this
path and be a sustainable economy yeah
and I believe it's coming I'm very
optimistic about it timeline I wish it
was tomorrow but yeah that won't happen
you know well we're taking steps now
we're doing our best yeah we're doing it
and remember the world the world wasn't
changed by reasonable people no it was
not okay you have to be unreasonable to
make the change let's let's check on
being unreasonable yeah we're
unreasonable together good on you Mitch
all right man well I think we should uh
end it on that man yeah
we want lots of people to be
unreasonable I know
I think it's good I appreciate it thanks
for the time congratulations thanks for
doing it man so if you want to uh
connect with Joe or learn more about uh
what Joe is up to go to
rebootwithjo.com right is that the best
place yep and um I'm on Twitter at uh at
Joe the juicer and also on uh Facebook
uh we've got a fat secondly dead page
and we've got a Joe Cross public profile
page right and there's fatsick and
nearly dead.com is up just as just some
information about the movie right yeah
and in the movie for those who haven't
seen it you can watch it on Netflix you
can watch it on Hulu
um you can go to iTunes Amazon it's on
all those platforms um and uh you know
one of the one of the really uh fun
things that we've been able to do is
because
um of our partnership with Breville is
that we've got some marketing dollars
which you know companies our size
wouldn't even dream of and so we've been
making some TV ads that are going to go
out in a couple of weeks Across America
so we're going to have these ads on TV
that are going to show the uh the
success stories of some people and try
and drive people to watch it online
that's going to be fun that's great so
um yeah so it's all it's all it's all
pretty cool and um you know the the
thing that that I'm I'm blowing away by
with is that if this didn't work the
fact that we're so open on social media
we get enough people telling us it
doesn't work I'm just blown away by I
don't get that I mean I get people
saying it was too hard and I had to stop
but I just don't ever get people saying
it didn't work and that is that that's
like really
kind of crazy when you think about it
you know you'd expect some people to say
oh you know I did the 10 days didn't
work but you don't you don't get that
you get everybody saying it was tough it
was hard but boy I feel amazing and
thanks so much and that was great so you
know and and by the way I didn't invent
it you didn't invent it this is
something that's been around from no
that's the only thing it's not a it's
not really a product you're just saying
drink drink a bunch of vegetables for 10
days and see how you feel there's
nothing proprietary about that roll the
dice
anyway man all right well you're right
you're an inspiration oh you are too I
really appreciate uh I appreciate the
time and I look forward to seeing the
new movie when it comes out and all the
TV shows and the media Empire that
you're building here just doing my best
man just do me I know you are too and
it's great to connect with other people
that are that are on the path so it's
it's a it's awesome and I'm sure we'll
see each other again I'll get you on one
of my shows absolutely right cool all
right thanks a lot peace Lance
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]